[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS'
WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
WATTERS WORDS.
BIDEN IS IN HIS FIRST YEAR AND
ALREADY A LAME DUCK.
THE COUNTRY DOESN'T TRUST HIM OR
RESPECT HIM.
WE WATCH HIM RESPOND TO PROPER
SLESMS SLOMY, CARELESS AND SLOW
LIKE HE'S INTOXICATED.
BIDEN AND THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
ARE SO OUT OF TOUCH WITH REALITY
THEY LIVE IN A FANTASY LANDS.
BUT THE MEDIA ISN'T REPEATING
BIDEN'S LIES AS MUCH AS THEY
USED TO.
>> MURDER IS WAY UP.
ALMOST 30%.
>> THE SUPPLY CHANNEL GRIDLOCK
IS GROWING.
>> A QUART MILLION SHIPPING
CONTAINERS REMAIN STUCK AT SEA.
>> CHAOS AT AIRPORTS NATIONWIDE.
SOUTHWEST AIR PLAINS FORCED TO
CANCEL FLIGHTS.
JESSE: BIDEN SAID INFLATION WILL
GO AWAY, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> OUR EXPERTS AGREE THAT THESE
BOTTLENECKS AND PRICE SPIKES
WILL REDUCE AS OUR ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO HEAL.
JESSE: THEY ARE GETTING WORSE.
PRICES ARE UP ON EVERYTHING,
FOOD, FURNITURE, AND ESPECIALLY
GAS.
>> LONG LINES.
LIKE A WHOLE BIG [INAUDIBLE]
>> IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS IF
YOU ARE TRAVELING YOU NEED.
IT'S A NECESSITY LIKE WATER.
>> $50 --
>> EVERY TIME I FILLED IT UP
WHEN TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE IT WAS
$45 TO $50 NOW IT STAKES $100 TO
FILL UP THE CAR.
JESSE: SOME OUTLETS ARE DEBASING
THEMSELVES TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT.
HERE IS "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
PROBABLY ON THE WHITE HOUSE
PAYROLL.
AMERICA NEEDS HIGHER LONGER
LASTING INFLATION.
THEY HATE THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY, THAT'S CLEAR.
CHRISTMAS WILL BE A MESS BECAUSE
PEOPLE CAN'T GET PRESENTS.
PORTS ARE MASSIVELY BACKLOGGED
IN LONG BEACH.
ALL THE PRODUCTS WE HAVE MADE IN
CHINA.
WE HAVE TO RE-LIE ON THEM FOR
EVERYTHING.
SO WHEN EVERYTHING IS MADE IN
CHINA IT TAKES FOREVER TO GET
THE PRODUCTS.
BIND AND HIS CRONIES PUT THE
FACTORIES THERE.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF CARGO SHIPS WAITING
TO DROP OFF THEIR ITEMS.
NOT YOU ENOUGH TRUCK DRIVERS TO
DRIVE THE PRODUCTS TO MARKET.
>> WE ARE AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS BEEN
CUT IN HALF BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
BUYING MORE GOODS BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE TRAVELING AND DEMAND IS UP
AND BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS
TURNING BACK ON.
JESSE: NOTHING IS WORKING
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ECONOMY IS SO
GREAT.
THAT'S THEIR TALKING POINT.
LIKE AFGHANISTAN.
NOTHING BUT A SUCCESS.
HIGH PRICES AND EMPTY SHELVES IS
A SIGN OF PROGRESS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT BIDEN THOUGHT
WHEN TRUMP WAS IN CHARGE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A FOOD SHORTAGE
PROBLEM WE HAVE A LEADERSHIP
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF FOOD.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING FIRED,
QUITTING, AND COMPANIES CAN'T
HIRE ANYBODY.
BIDEN BLAMED YOU INSTEAD.
>> IF THE PRIVATE SECTOR DOESN'T
STEP YOU WILL WE'LL CALL THEM
OUT TO GET THEM TO ACT.
OUR GOAL IS TO ADDRESS THE LONG
STANDING WEAKNESSES IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SUPPLY KLAIN THAT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED.
>> IT'S ALL OUR FAULT.
LIKE HE BLAMES THE POLICE, THE
BORDER PATROL AND THE PEOPLE HE
LEFT BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE BUCK DOESN'T STOP WITH
BIDEN.
WE CAN'T FLIGHT EITHER.
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES SEEING
THOUSANDS OF FLIGHTS CANCELED
AND THEY EXPECT IT TO LAST
THROUGH THE HOLIDAYS.
PILOTS ARE PROTESTING THE VAX
MANDATE.
THE CEO SAID HE DOESN'T WANT TO
DO THE MANDATE BUT HE HAS TO
BECAUSE BIDEN FORCED HIS HAND.
IN SEATTLE AND L.A., A HUGE
PORTION OF POLICE OFFICERS COULD
GET LAID OFF FOR REFUSING THE
VAX MANDATE.
IT WON'T KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
WHILE THE PROBLEMS CONTINUE TO
PILE UP LIKE CRAZY, VP KAMALA
HARRIS HAS BEEN UP TO NOTHING.
A NASA SPACE VIDEO WITH KIDS TO
TRY TO MAKE HERSELF LOOK
RELATABLE.
>> TO THINK OF HOW MUCH IS OUT
THERE THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
LEARN.
I LOVE THAT.
I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
SPACE COUNCIL.
YOU WILL SEAT CRATERS ON THE
MOON WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
I'M TELLING YOU IT WILL BE
UNBELIEVABLE.
JESSE: THOSE WEREN'T REAL KIDS.
THOSE WERE HIRED CHILD ACTORS.
THE COMPANY WAS CANADIAN.
SHE DIDN'T EVEN USE AN AMERICAN
COMPANY.
THE COMPANY IS CALLED SINKING
SHIP PRODUCTION.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TELLING YOUR CHILDREN YOU CAN'T
GET THE ONE SPECIAL PRESENT THEY
PUT ON THEIR CHRISTMAS LIST.
THE AGONY OF BEING STRANDED AT
THE AIRPORT AFTER ANOTHER
CANCELED FLIGHT.
BIDEN DOESN'T CARE.
HE'S NOT EVEN DOING ANYTHING TO
SHOW HE CARES LIKE A LOW GRADE
POLITICIAN WOULD.
FAKE WHITE HOUSE SETS, PAID
ACTORS, SPIN, LIES.
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
CALLED HIGH PRICES SHY CLASS
PROBLEMS.